established during the Great Depression
the Social Security retirement system is
funded by a twelve point four percent
tax split between workers and employers
on all wages up to a hundred thirteen
thousand dollars it's the nation's
oldest entitlement program and one of
its most beloved yet it's also a fiscal
and demographic disaster that
desperately needs to be reformed right
now for at least three reasons
yours Social Security Social Security is
already paying out more in benefits than
it brings in via payroll taxes it makes
up the difference by drawing on
surpluses built up over the past decades
but according to the most recent report
by Social Security's trustees those
surpluses will be totally gone in 2033
and unless taxes get jacked up the
system will only be able to pay 75
percent of current benefits your Social
Security
people think of social security as a
retirement account but it yields a
terrible rate of return researchers at
the liberal Urban Institute estimate
that virtually all people retiring in
2010 or later will receive far less and
benefits than they paid into the system
via payroll taxes
nobody would stand for that in a
voluntary retirement plan your Social
Security not only will younger workers
get smaller benefits if they get any
benefits at all we have no control over
our contributions we can't will our
contributions or savings to heirs the
result is less disposable income now and
in retirement whatever since it may have
once made Social Security is now a
program that is insolvent and unfair and
that will only get worse as the baby
boom generation starts retiring on mass
if we want to protect seniors from
poverty and old age we should address
that directly through welfare payments
rather than creating and extending a
system that pits one generation against
the other for Reason TV I'm Nicholas T